turning red is disney pixar's latest
film and totally not what happened to me
when i got rejected by my prom date
director domi she set this film in my
hometown of toronto canada and i'm just
a little upset there weren't any
appearances by drake or justin bieber
can you imagine if we did a birthday
cake
waffle timbit this man is a genius there
is however a dreamy boy band by the name
of four town which has got to be a mix
of oh town and toronto based boy band
before four
[Music]
yeah that was a thing so in this video
we'll be taking a deep dive into turning
red it's ending easter eggs including
ones hinting at the new lightyear movie
and a whole lot more if i may here's our
film's protagonist maymay a 13 year old
girl who has developed an unusual skill
of turning into my worst nightmare a
furry her given name melin comes from
chinese meaning beautiful rose which i
thought was a great choice considering
the film's emphasis on red and accepting
who we are all her life may's lived by
one rule the number one rule in my
family
honor your
parents a theme which is expressed in
other asian focused disney films such as
mulan
[Music]
but as may notes early on if you live
your entire life honoring your parents
you may forget to honor yourself our
introduction to may is filled with tons
of cool easter eggs here you can see
iconic toronto landmarks like this cn
tower and skydome the film is set in
2002 so if you were to go to toronto
today this skydome is now called the
rogers center all hail are corporate
overlords mae carries with her a
tamagotchi a popular toy from the early
2000s it also acts as a metaphor for the
changes mae experiences tamagotchis
would change and evolve with love and
care just like mayweal she calls hers
robert jr named after one of the singers
in 4-town fun fact my parents couldn't
afford to get me a tamagotchi so i had
to get the knock-off version a dinky
dino the attention to detail about
toronto here is staggering here are the
toronto streetcars and they even got the
interiors of them correct may's school
named after canadian prime minister
lester b pearson is where we're
introduced to may's friends miriam abby
and priya the daisy mart where dreamboat
devon works is an actual chain of
convenience stores found around the city
even the musical notes in the back here
play the canadian national anthem in the
background of chinatown which toronto
has one of the largest of in north
america we can see bao restaurant named
after the short film the director won an
oscar for in 2019. you can even make up
this dragon sculpture in the background
called gateway which marks the main
intersection of chinatown for may life
is a mix of honoring her parents and
being true to herself at least that's
what she thinks her mother basically has
full control over her i do make my own
moves it's just that
some of my moves are
also hers if she's gonna grow into a
young woman who makes her own decisions
some big changes are gonna have to be
made let's introduce soon-yi mei's and
sister of whom the temple is built
around legend says that she asked the
gods to turn her into a red panda to
protect her family when the men went off
to war and ever since then the red panda
blessing has been passed down to every
female in the family however this
blessing is now seen more as a curse for
you canadians out there you might
remember the colors in this logo when
the ad for the four-town concert plays
it's for much music basically the
canadian version of mtv but the real
story doesn't really begin until may
turns into her fursona for the first
time yes i just said that one of the
most crucial scenes in the movie is mate
literally turning red as her mother
embarrasses her in front of dreamy devin
revealing her lovey-dovey drawings in
front of her schoolmates and you know
it's a canadian convenience store when
they sell maple syrup it's here we can
really see how mei's mother ming is
overprotective of her daughter she
constantly keeps watching her at school
and forbids anything that may dishonor
the family and it's the day after this
huge embarrassment that mae first turns
into this panda with her mother
mistaking mae's odd behavior as her
getting her first period gin it's
happening my god okay it's happening may
will soon find out that it's not just
embarrassment which turns her into a red
panda but any heightened emotion thus
may's turning becomes a metaphor for her
having no control over her life or her
own choices just like she has no control
over her life she also has no control
over the panda but when her mom finds
out mei has this mystical power it's
time to tell her the truth this is an
affliction that runs in the family but
there is a cure at the next red moon a
ritual can be performed to trap the
panda forever which is something all the
women in the lee family have done but
there's just one problem the big four
town concert that she wants to go to
more than anything ever is before the
ritual if she can prove to her mom that
she can control this panda maybe she can
go she even makes a sweet slideshow
there's just one other problem the
tickets cost 200 bucks each so may
devises a plan to hustle her panda and
sell merch for some sweet sweet loonies
and toonies yes our money is called
loonies and toonies but every time mei
lets out the panda it will make the
ritual harder to perform but each time
you do
the stronger it gets
and then you'll be bound to it forever
when ming discovers that her daughter
has been secretly using her panda power
she shows up at this guy tyler's place
we don't like tyler and chastises her
friends for putting may up to this and
may has the opportunity to tell the
truth to her mother and explain it was
actually all her idea but may doesn't as
she'll say later on her obsession with
her mom's approval was too strong i've
been like obsessed with my mom's
approval my whole life i couldn't take
losing it losing you guys feels even
worse and if things couldn't get any
worse mae finds out that the four-town
concert is the same night as her ritual
so all that hard work she put into going
was for nothing one of may's aunts makes
reference to the number four being
unlucky in chinese culture that's
because it sounds a lot like the
cantonese word for death although ming
also went through this ritual when she
was younger she never opens up to me
about her experience that's because ming
and her mother had a big fight which
it's implied resulted in grandmother
getting this scar over her eye this is
part of the reason why ming is so
adamant her daughter banishes the panda
she doesn't want to see her go through
this same pain and falling out that she
experienced with her own mother in
typical disney fashion there's always
that one character who's wiser than the
rest in turning red this falls on may's
father jinn he's a side character for
much of the film but shares a
heartwarming scene with his daughter
about being different people have all
kinds of sides to them me and some sides
are
messy the point isn't to push the bad
stuff away it's to make room for it it's
the complete opposite mentality of ming
and the other women of the family who
have pushed away this quote unquote bad
side their entire lives on the night of
the red moon mae is ready to undergo the
ritual which involves summoning a portal
to may's ancestral plane it's there her
ancestor suni holds a mirror to her
allowing her to separate the panda from
her body trapping it into the medallion
found on mr gao's sword but as she looks
back at this panda that has actually
helped her grow as a person she can't
let go of it this is one of the first
times in the movie where mei makes her
own decision finally taking control of
her own life a decision which goes
against her mother's wishes as she
escapes her family her mother's
medallion which contains her panda
cracks and just like may's panda appears
during moments of heightened emotion so
too does mings whose angered her
daughter went against her will the
film's climax takes place at the sky
dome where the toronto blue jays play
hence why a blue jay is here near the
end and what mae thought would be a time
to make up with her friends and enjoy
the soothing sounds of four town goes to
hell when her mother's godzilla-like
panda bears down on the dome get it
bears down uh ming tells her daughter
that this isn't who she is but in an act
of defiance mae stands up for herself
[Music]
very canadian with all those sorries she
knocks her mother out but if they're
gonna get her into that ritual circle
mae will need the strength of her family
to drag her back into it that's when her
family shatter their jewelry unleashing
their pandas to help mei even fourtown
joins in to help sing which is all part
of the ritual process i always knew the
ancient chinese had an affinity for boy
bands the plan seems to work and soon
may is transported back to the ancestral
plane where she sees a young version of
her mother crying she's crying because
she hurt her mother and it's here we see
why ming has been such an overbearing
and protective mother she has become the
thing she hated while growing up her own
mother i'm just so sick of being perfect
i'm never gonna be good enough for her
or anyone may tells her that it isn't
true and that she's good enough and as
she leads her back we see her mother
grow older back to her normal age at the
portal back to the real world her family
awaits ming and grandmother make up
after all these years but it's time for
may to make her own final decision on
what she's gonna do i'm finally figuring
out who i am but
i'm scared it'll take me away from you
her mother says not to hold herself back
and that she couldn't be prouder and
with that mae embraces her panda and
decides to have it be a part of her
may's family have their pandas in a
colorful new assortment of containers
like mings and may's old tamagotchi and
grandmothers in a four-town necklace the
damage at the skydome runs in the
millions of dollars so naturally the lee
family turns the temple into a tourist
attraction now equipped with the red
panda herself to help pay off the bill
mei ends posing a question to us the
viewer we all have an inner wild and
weird side that we keep hidden away a
lot of us never let it out but mae
embraced hers and grew as a person
because of it will you keep yours hidden
or will you let yours out now for some
more fun with extra easter eggs tyler
here wears a number 15 purple basketball
jersey which was the number of star
player vince carter for the toronto
raptors back in 2002. the bagsport
backpack here is a playoff up popular
backpack brand jansport here's a top
deck that miniature skateboard in the
back here we can see a little stuffed
bear with a maple leaf on it a nod to
the toronto maple leafs hockey team this
actually appears throughout the film
like here in the background in chinatown
at twilight spoof nightfall by author
roberta moyer the real author's name is
stephanie mayer in maeve's room on her
notepad we can see a burro bunny sticker
and a pearl plushie on her desk which
are characters from disney pixar's spark
shorts program which was created to
highlight new storytellers and how about
some delicious tim horton's timbits a
canadian delicacy and you know pixar
always loves to throw in easter eggs for
their upcoming movies in this case it's
lightyear which you can find the logo
for star command on the back of miriam's
skateboard there's almost always a pizza
planet easter egg like here when may's
trying to make it to the concert another
staple a113 the number of the pixar
animation classroom at the california
institute of the arts which can be found
on the four town ticket in the end
credits abby's character also looks like
she's dressed like boo's door from
monsters inc and last but certainly not
least this one took me forever to find
but the luxo ball which can be found
floating in the pool during the party
scene that's it for this video like and
subscribe to help the channel out and
leave a comment on what you thought
about the movie or if you found any
extra easter eggs thanks for watching
everyone and for more bad takes you can
always follow me on twitter and
instagram at thingstoryt until next time
remember